yeah
a battle for power with no end in sight
a national Army that governs the country
and a paramilitary force that operates
with impunity head to head in the
capital and Beyond with symbolic
strongholds burnt to a husk
millions of civilians are caught in the
crossfire forced to stay at home but
even there they are unsafe
look at the damage to our house says
Ahmed an engineer in whose entire family
was sleeping when a shell hit his 15
year old brother was injured by the
shrapnel
bullets Rockets I don't know what is it
then totally from nowhere
there are the rocket hit our house and
it is very very bad damage can you leave
the house right now if you needed to
I can't leave the house very dangerous
outside uh
the the military is everywhere I don't
know who who are they
[Music]
everything outside is
miserable I can't imagine what what
what's gonna happen if I leave our my
home
[Music]
while the Army has gained control of key
sites in the capital the rapid support
forces have the upper hand in Darfur
thousands are fleeing and dozens killed
including three staff members of the
world food program it's not just that
Ford has also been shaken by violence
I'm going to call a human rights monitor
there now to find out what's going on
are you expecting the death toll to go
up today
since morning at four P for four o'clock
morning up to right now
the the sound of this heavy weapons
[Music]
Sudan's power struggle has long been an
area of mediation and now the much
feared crisis has hit talks are at a
Tipping Point with key Regional and
International Players like the UN U.S
and Saudi Arabia calling for a cessation
of hostilities and Egypt offering to
mediate
we caution against the danger of
escalating violence and the
unpredictable consequences that may
ensue domestically and regionally
thank you
both sides have shown an unwillingness
to end the violence the country now
waits to see who will emerge Victorious
and how high the price of Peace will
ultimately be
[Music]
used Sky News